Over the last century and a half or so, humans,
as a group, have grown significantly taller,
with men from western, industrialized countries
today being on average between 3 and 7 inches
(7-18 cm) taller than their counterparts in
the mid-19th century.
So why have humans gotten taller?
There is very strong evidence that this simply
comes down to nutrition and the body’s ability
to fully benefit from said nutrition via not
getting certain diseases that hinder the absorption
of consumed nutrients.
That the environment is drastically more important
than other factors, such as microevolution,
is strongly indicated via looking at human
height during times of relative comfort compared
with times of strife.
For example, examination of skeletons over
human history has shown that, while there
have been peaks and valleys of average height
across different cultures at different times,
from the Stone Age through the beginning of
the 19th century there has been little significant
difference in average human height on the
whole.
As for the peaks and valleys, during the Black
Death (1346-1353), 60% of the European population,
about 50 million people, died quite suddenly,
leaving the surviving 40% and their offspring
with greater access to food and less crowded
living conditions; together, this contributed
to fewer diseases and better nutrition, and
as a result, people during the 15th and 16th
centuries in Europe grew rather tall.
In fact, in England, the average man was only
about 1.5 inches (3.81 cm) shorter during
this time compared with the average Englishman
today (at about 5’9″ or 175 cm).
Seventeenth century Europe, however, was a
mess, with cold winters from the Little Ice
Age limiting crop production, civil war in
England, Louis XIV’s expansionary aggression
and the Thirty Years’ War.
As a result, human health and height suffered,
with the average Frenchman reaching only about
5’4″ (162 cm).
(Not coincidentally why French men popularized
wearing high-heels around this time, a practice
that women would later adopt and men largely
abandon, outside of horse riding boots.)
Faring little better during the 18th and early
parts of the 19th century, many western Europeans
lived in dirty, disease-ridden slums that
prevented them from increasing significantly
in height, with men across Europe in 1850
only reaching, on average, about 5’5″
(165 cm).
Starkly marking the difference proper diet
and living conditions can make here is that
19th century English students at the Sandhurst
Military Academy (upper class) were on average
a whopping 8.7 inches (22 cm) taller than
their compatriots at the Marine Society boys
(lower class).
In the United States, things were quite different,
with the average man in 1850 attaining a height
of about 5’7″ (170 cm).
In fact, on average, people in the U.S. remained
taller than their European counterparts from
the Revolutionary War through World War II
(with a slight dip during the second industrial
revolution).
It is thought that American height dominance
during this period was due to having a relatively
resource-rich environment, where, with the
largely privately owned agriculture-based
society, many had easier access to a wider
variety of nutrition sources than was common
in places like the UK, where a very small
percentage of people owned much of the land
being farmed and much higher population densities
existed.
(See: Why the Mass Avoidance of Some Business
is Called Boycotting)
historical-median-male-heightThings began
to change after WWII.
In the last half century or so, the average
American height has more or less remained
the same, while post-war Europeans have, on
the whole, sprouted like crazy.
In the most extreme case, throughout the 19th
century men and women of the Netherlands averaged
roughly 5’5″ (166 cm) for men and 5’1″
(156 cm) for women- relatively short for their
era and region of the world.
Today, the tallest people in the world are
found in the Netherlands, where the average
man is just over 6 feet tall (183 cm) and
the average woman is nearly 5’7″ (170
cm).
By comparison, American men are 5’9″ (175
cm) on average, and women are 5’4″ (163
cm).
Some believe that the great strides in height
made by Western Europeans over Americans can
be attributed to their universal health coverage
and other social policies, such as maternity
services and greater parental leave allowing
for better practicality of things like breastfeeding
vs. formula fed and, later, more time off
work providing extra time for preparing nutritious
meals, rather than relying on fast-food and
other quick high-calorie, low nutrition “junk”
foods.
Further, the so-called “over-nutrition”
prevalent in the U.S., combined with lack
of physical activity leading to widespread
obesity, has also been noted for its negative
effects on growth hormones and metabolism,
limiting the ultimate adult height somewhat.
So how high will humans grow with perfect
nutrition and health care?
It’s generally thought the Dutch are close
to the peak of average human height potential,
at least based on innate genetics, and Americans
and others are close to it.
This is probably a good thing as the human
body is not adapted well for extreme height,
and those outliers who do tower over the rest
of us often suffer from various pains and
other debilities related to their abnormal
height as they age.